how do you know the difference between
loving film versus loving filmmaking
oh
um
I think I Fall In and Out of filmmaking
loving filmmaking and I never fall out
of love with film
because filmmaking is so hard you know
it's it's uh
it's a commitment to a time period and
it's just hard work and so we always
kind of you know I've never given birth
but you always give it like you forget
the labor when you have the finished
product and then you immediately want to
do another movie because you've
forgotten how hard that movie was I
think that's very true with filmmaking
um where's like film like would I find a
good film I love it you know and like
the best ones for me are the ones where
I can stop thinking about how did they
shoot this what location is this you
know whatever ideas about the actual
production you know if I can like just
immerse myself in it and just go on the
dream with it that's my favorite thing
why did you choose filmmaking over music
I don't know that it was a
cognizant Choice like I'm done with
music I'm gonna do film now only
um I just think like there are more
opportunities in film somehow which is
is a weird thing to say
um I tried like I gave all my 20s to
music I tried really hard and I just
kind of Hit the ceiling
uh for opportunities I feel like you
know as far as I was gonna go
um but I still love doing music and I
want to get back into it but since
moving to La I've just been like the
tunnel vision ahead doing filmmaking
um and just like the songs you know they
haven't been coming you know as as
frequently and it's probably because I'm
not doing it as much you know so
I might get back into it we'll see we'll
see I've got another record in me for
sure
um but yeah I don't think it was like a
choice like I'm done with this you know
because I love music too you know it's
never going to go away that's my first
love
um
yeah film just called to me I don't know
was there a day that you remember where
like a number of things had happened
you're just like I'm okay I'm out of
music for a little bit or
I mean was there like some a turning
point like a specific incident ah no
because I think if I were if I were
still in Boston I'd probably still be in
a couple bands
um
so I think there was a slow realization
at some point that I wasn't going to be
some big rock star you know
whereas like that was always the Dream
from when I was like eight years old and
like it's you know I'll get to a city
I'll be a rock star I'll be whatever
number one
um and at some point you know you figure
out like all right that's you know for
whatever reason of uh privilege and and
knowing the right people and all the
business side of things that you slowly
learn like maybe you learned a little
too slow like how the business actually
works you know
um
you know there was like a slow
realization like okay I've taken this as
far as I probably can take it and it's
pretty much like at a professional
hobbyist level you know like I play gigs
I get paid for them I can do a tour once
in a while it kind of pays for itself
but I'm not making career level money
out of it
um
and that's fine you know I I'm proud of
the music and I'm proud of the Bands but
you know you realize like
how much are you gonna keep putting into
that that Circle that doesn't seem to be
growing
um and part of it I think was being in
Boston too it's like a small city
um and it like you know you always think
like oh we're so close to New York like
it'll work out but it never does you
know like you can't even go to New York
enough to make that work you know as
business-wise not working wise
um but for whatever reason like film at
that time in the 2000s when like dslrs
exploded suddenly it seemed like you
could be making film everywhere and I
think that's still true to an extent you
can make your film in in whatever City
and you can go to the same festivals as
the LA filmmakers go to if your film is
good enough and so I think it felt a
little bit like location it matter as
much though now I do believe being in La
does help me a lot as far as taking my
work to the next level and especially as
working on other people's projects much
easier to do that from La even if I'm
traveling
um so I think there was a time when I
was like I gotta go to La but to start
um it just felt like I could do that
from anywhere and still grow a career
because like if to me if something isn't
growing then I'm like well what else can
I do so I think like with music was like
it wasn't hard enough like what else is
harder I could start over at you know
it's maybe my 40s I'm like I'm gonna do
this now but I don't know what the next
thing is you know Ceramics who knows
but you know it's 20s is music 30s is
film we'll see where if as long as it
feels like I'm moving ahead creatively
artistically and business-wise I'm gonna
keep doing it
what's the most important part of the
filmmaking process
oh man for me
I like just getting into the
collaboration aspects of it
um getting people in a room this is like
my only social time is making films
because otherwise I'm very much of a
hermit like I'm like the introverted
extrovert I like like a lot and then I'm
like I like silence
um so it's like I you know I get all the
people in the room we get to hang out we
get to think as one we get to have a
goal in mind that to me is the most
important part
um and then of course the end product
you know because like whatever you did
doesn't matter if then product is crap
or if it was a struggle in the end
product is good then it was worth it you
know
um but yeah for me from for my brain
it's it's the soup getting everybody in
the room together and doing all that all
that pre-pro just to get to that point
is already you've done so much even just
to enter set on the first day and then
you've got to do that whole big chunk
um yeah so it's a collaboration I think
you can't do film so much solo you know
and music you can and in film you can't
so much you have to find your people
what are the best movies to watch to
learn the craft of filmmaking I think
any film is going to give you something
if you're watching it critically
you know you can see why does the
sequence work or not work you know once
you watch it once and then you can go
back and be like okay well where the
angles off were they really good did
they do some cool water you know like
around a space
um I think you can learn something from
just about any film once you start
breaking it down
um and I find that part of my brain very
hard to turn off you know like thinking
about what lenses what focal lengths
they use thinking about like oh this
hasn't cut in a really long time but
it's been really interesting you know
and I haven't seen a cut uh
so yeah I think
just about anything I mean my favorites
I love 70s films and I think like that
um
you know the camera's much more
motivated because Steadicam was new and
I don't think a lot of people were using
it yet and so it's like if you were
gonna make that choice to to move the
camera on a dolly or Steadicam like it
was for a reason and I like that like I
don't like a lot of unnecessary you know
like Michael Bay Style just watching
Michael Bay movie I'm like oh my God I
can't even concentrate like you know
um
so
you know I think like for me it's going
back to the 70s Cinema I think it's just
so beautiful and like every picture is a
painting you know every frame is a
painting
um but I think you can learn anything
from just about anything you know even
watching the Michael Bay movie I was
like oh my gosh like
drone shot drone shot I'm like uh I
learned I didn't like it really fast but
I'm like is this what people want I
don't know
I need to know it
but do I need to like it now or even
from the first Jason Bourne movie which
I loved but then you see the next one
and you can see how fast things have
changed like how much we're used to just
such
rapid movement rapid information like
Everything's changed oh yeah yeah I
watched ambulance on the plane uh
recently and it was just like constant
cutting and I was like you don't need to
go from a close-up on a face to a drone
shot back to a close-up like it's too
much for my brain to process where we
are you know and I think it loses the
story a little bit when there's a lot of
unnecessary camera movement I think you
lose track of where you are in a scene
you know because like if you're just
watching the camera didn't do stuff you
know it's I think it takes you out or it
makes the camera too present because you
want to forget that the camera's there I
think depending on the style but um you
know you want to feel very natural that
it's moving or like if you're building
tension and very slowly pushing in
something like that like that's working
for the moment of the story but once
it's just like we just need to be
cutting constantly and we need to be
like moving constantly
I think it just feeds into our
Collective add
you said you loved Italian Cinema like
the 70s Italian Cinema who introduced
you to that
um I think just uh you know Michael and
I just discovered it as as we dug deeper
you know we're always looking for
something weirder to watch and
um yeah I think it's become very popular
over the last few years to know Dario
Argento and denosa spirit and stuff but
a couple years ago like we kind of went
through all the hammer horror and we uh
we did our like little Hammer vampire
movie and then like as we dug deeper
into those those early 70s years we're
like oh this is what the Italians are
doing they're doing giallo they're doing
very colorful lighting and like then you
realize like oh there's hundreds of
these even now like when we watched the
first 50 I was like oh man I've seen
every giallo good job me and then it's
like the next year another small label
comes out with another 20 and you're
like oh my God these guys were prolific
you know there's always more being
discovered and they're all really
interesting because
to me 50 years later whatever it's been
it seems very dreamy and it seems like
they were doing very interesting things
with the art of it you know like
foreground like putting mirrors
Reflections
um you know they were experimenting with
what the visual was doing it's like and
they're very weird in that way and I
like that